it's good we continue in this nursery probos
2013 Bogota edition the live previous to the
grand finale the great we are living
his impressive successes comes the
great final and I want to meet the
exactly winner and you who are there
connected that you were seeing in the
social approach of course each of
the comments you can continue talking
next to us defining and detecting
and visualizing everything that is
occurring in each of the groups
enjoying with us of course of
all the technology of google it is
here in the Colombian ecosystem in favor
of SMEs in favor of these firms
we are building the regional
applications and of course as you
may have been able to see on the day of
yesterday in the presentation they are very
interesting so it's up to us the subject of
google + the subject is also touched to go
integrating different elements of
youtube we are on the day of the
black integration correctly day of
the integration all groups by
supposedly very nervously giving the
final details of each of your
Projects
and delineating refining the back much more
end of course also in the details
of the front end and on the day of
good integration by placing the feet already
Some of the groups are working
on prediction and foot and yes and here we go
to see now some concepts of how
make it more social about how to place the
walk button haining some parts
of javascript
a little html we are also going to see
how to connect to the youtube channel
analytic of the youtube channel was cited
because I'm good that's also very
important when we have scenarios
multimedia detect if bring the
videos see how many views we have like this
what are we going to do very easy
authorizing us to youtube and in this
case version 3 since it brings some
very interesting features and for
Of course we are going to keep going
groups follows the spy camera too
follow in second you will also be able
detect with that
you were wind that in the first the
alive two couples have danced good one
of them has won that was the couple
number one couple number two did not have
the necessary votes so what
let's do is check the code together
one of the mentors already saw it to mayer
Over there
concentrated so go out there I was
also turning around so we're going to
analyze the code of these two groups
the couple was made up of 8 and
the 10th remember so let's review
the application also they and you that
you're connected there, you'll say they're going to
do now because I'm watching I'm
preparing the popcorn they said some
of those in the virtual audience of the
person becomes increasingly fun
the one of belo forgiveness and we combine code
technique with fun of course and you
successes later I tell you if a
tremendous challenge let's play a
virtual game if we are going to play a game
virtual is also built with
html5 very interesting with our elves
you will be able to live live comes the
challenge to see how many in a few more you're going to
play paco
let's see where that comes from
comes the great challenge so that you
you are there connected to the proposal is
integration code we are going to have fun
also socially and let's see what
is happening with the groups we are going to
ask also about how they feel
because if the grand finale arrives they are
minutes of presenting an application that
work and that helps SMEs
regional exactly 4 34 30 pm hour
from bogotá we remember the use of -5 what
you can find very simple in
google developers is an event the
grand finale here in colombia so no
you worry you can also follow by
course the developer community
and everything goes much much much more than
3,700 successes and of course
google developers also that follows
growing you put +1 tennis also like
followers as a follower and they are more than
13,000 buses and taxis that impressive
lot of developers in
Latin America that are accompanying us
and of course for us it is a
pleasure so we remind you that and you
we remember that all the news
also and minute minutes are lived
money
along with the portal that has even
the projects the teams and all the
information not only from Bogota but
also from Buenos Aires of my city of
mexico protest all the videos
also that we were enjoying sao
paulo record of poland paola the earth
of the samba is vallenato there will be
samba whether it is spoken or cited like that
well it will be good
we concentrate then we go to
heat engines the stage comes
technical the conversation with the
mentors the challenge comes too and
let's evaluate code so we
we prepare we prepare ourselves
we concentrate and we are already in second
with much more if well approved 2013
edit vote
well we continue in this nursery post 2013
Bogota edition here enjoying with the
group of course and all the adrenaline
technological to you that are there
connected to you who are there told me
you have to modify the
nomenclature what you are saying to voice
to you so I'm talking to you
you are there connected yes we continue
enjoying all that adrenaline and
We continue talking with the groups but
paco would like to see a bit to see what happens
in the social network because we are
accompanying are commenting there are some
requests that are asking us to
the camera is think go to group number
let's see to see let's see for the
group number 9 to see if it arrives
I need help look how it takes
as we are there, we greet group 9
barbarian group number 9 we can send
what are they doing now that they are
making see if we can see their
computers
there it is to see well
with respect to the maps it seems that yes
that makes sense
look what barbarian of course good is going to
follow of course much more camera in
I live for ccoo we have some other
message and then tell us to see if
there's more social effect but let's see
very quickly because it's coming at 4
30pm and do not miss the grand finale
come the jurors are evaluating all
the applications technically we have
technical evaluation criteria
criteria of course of entrepreneur
also to complete this tremendous
application that is totally left
available on open source license and
for all regional SMEs very
important so in this nursery post
2013 to whom in the Bogota edition and in
all Latin America we are telling
contribute directly to this
tremendous ecosystem of regional SMEs
more than 99 percent of the companies in
Latin America are SMEs as we are not going to
contribute buses milestones and more than 30
ecosystems and with all the potential of
the technologies of google nor by
supposed
so come with me your successes let's go
watching quickly
and let's do a javascript review
with html to integrate google + all the
potential of the social approach also
that many of the groups are also
using to not make that record to
somewhat more tedious times of a
form with last name is no longer
authentic moss socially and of that
way we start to interact that is
one of the most important things and that
they are here I am quickly showing
so that developers can
locate all this potential where you searched
information about google + and how
integrate it very simple very good developers
dot google.com reference address
reference address for every bar
more bar more so saying perfect very
we can well find out why all
the information as initial how to do
that secure authentication that we decide
the curp haining them in which with the
ping button we click and we
authenticates moss in the post social network
interactive good how we integrate
with padlock there is also a simple way
to integrate into hangouts and generate
applications or extensions so that I
I'm doing a
video conference I'm talking
with someone can start to interact
today we will see very quickly the
first of the examples yes but they have
all the information here available and
they are going to what platform they are going to
be working and example javascript
so that you can use I want
do only one shortcut
to the skin and very simple look here now
I'm working on one of the
examples
I have google + that open and the code
number one good what basically does
this code is to login with a
button let's see how it is built
this yes very quickly here what
let's find
here we have some of the little things
let's look for that code because we have
many files
All shipping of course we show it to you
notice how fast and how simple we are
to do here I have the code 1 html point
I'm showing you we have a
rendering function here what
we are using of course is the bugle
there is that we are locating the same
project that was commenting
previously and with the same number by
Of course this is part of the api
google to be part of the whole console
that we are talking about all the services
that is available google so much
I have to generate a project for me or if I already
I have a project and go activate the
console and that's what we show them
also in the previous broadcast I will go
to the console here I have all my
projects located one of the projects
within space and author and authentication
authorization yes here I have all the
feet notice that for you to
functions I have to have of course
enabled on the google chrome display and
we started to see then the
first data that we place is the
training
we have to feel the scout in this
case the scope that we are using is
login
because we are going to make an ass sign in without
nothing more than that and then good once
that I have these entities or I have something of
style that is is lateral with
of course the branding debuts them so that
you see the little button as you
they know that we can vary the
according to the official branding and finally
we have only one dip that does the
call to this zenit bulla is very simple
what we are showing you, notice that
here we have the function that this
operation is very very simple how to
that in which I can use asses
sajnín so this one the proposal that
we are bringing very
quickly how to authorize us and
start working with google + haining
it's that simple, I'm already of course
I do not have any more operations to perform
in this case but it identifies me and of that
way I can already tell you that I am such or
which authentic person something very useful
for the applications that are here for
course and that's what it's about
that's why we were sharing it
you can see we are going to upload this
code that is very small and that
really provide very much functionality
interesting and in fact remember that
our portal has this technology
also of course so, so we must
see two points with google.com for
course so for ccoo as well that
social network there are messages like that we
they are saying that we are beginning to have
public support for teams and Ivan
wheels by number 7 wicks by the
number 8 then make your predictions
and friends tell us what team they like
to win this developer you who
will win who will win not like we were
with that but well then we follow a
little bit more and neither is telling us anymore
in detail how they are bouncing all the
audience you're there connected to
each of the groups having the
good preference those votes add up are going to
be taken into account of course is
true in fact you have to remind
all that
one of the ratings one of the
seven grades that receive the
groups is the number of votes in their
team publications then vote
for the one that they like the best they can
vote for several also if they like
more of a clearing of course so it's
very important because it is part of the
qualification so surely the
groups are going to get very happy yes
yes they are supporting them externally and the
dance also add dance pole
also sum and good clear out there
until it is not the valuation of
project but yes in that social framework
I think so because it helps that they have a
+1 go away be well follow more one
exactly so well we follow a
little reviewing we quickly saw a
javascript bit
very small that allows me to be the ass
zhenning with some very simple styles
but we also want to talk a little bit about
what happens with youtube that is
basically the demo that we're going to see
it has to do with the analytical that
we can do many things we can
edit a playlist we can work
different activities with respect to
the videos that is very important the
multimedia scenario we do not have great
number of solutions
that can be based on videos that
there are nowadays that are millions of
videos that are happening daily by
by youtube that are playing and
that we can get that
information I will show you by
course then something called topic
explorer also in which uses the
youtube play and also use something that
call freebase and then we can
detect the knowledge if from
youtube for example let's use the
use my channel if not the channel
personal and based on what I'm going
looking in the channel is going to detect me
concepts those concepts seek them
freebase yes they are objects in triads
person objects for the general public
they are objects and it returns me if the quantity
of objects that represent those
concepts that I have in my channel
Let's imagine that I like to see I do not know
for example musical themes of vallenato
for example to learn to dance
vallenato good because not if it would have
that represent that so very
interesting good to see then
quickly here we have prepared
let's see something from a collage of
very simple analytics on the html
to show here this synthetic removes I say
it's good to basically search the channel
if I search the videos of my channel
I have to select one of the videos and
based on that generate me a graph of
contest the foot that demonstrates a
number of visits or regularity
irregularity of the visits that I
we had how this is built we go
to use our of your successes because
then we keep integrating look
we quickly see the code here we're going to
see it also a little more in detail
because it is also important that we go
detecting each of the parties step to
I pass the exact recipe within html not
we have nothing but all the magic does
this javascript that we have here and here
we have the integration as you
will be able to see again use the
client the clan there is of the scouts I follow
it tends again what areas I need
to give instructions to the entity and
concrete note that after I'm already
working with some formulas here
authorized that it is part foundation
here it is already authorized because we are
manipulating it here live but good and
after we are handling the
results and in this very simple way
I can go detecting here we have the
concrete integration if loading the
foot law interface here we also have
the the return of the channel of the
user as I told them in this case
of course we are using my channel
because I'm authorizing here is
complete the answer we are seeing
here we have for example the return
of the playlist because we could
work with some specific videos
with some particular playlist that
course it is depending on what
programming we are giving you here
we are returning the metadata of those
videos is very important that you
can detect and analyze each of
these lines because within the goal
data there is a lot of information from the videos
we can know if a video is musical if
a video is about culture if a video is
accepted technology technology in
reality based on that we can get
a lot of knowledge information from
what is happening in the channel and by
we name them here live yes
then that is important and good final
here we are showing with this function
the analytics
of concrete data if it's a bit long
to detail all the code but
finally for you to understand
here we have the integration with charts and
in this way if we already round xii of
we outlined the development completely
authorize us let's bring the channel a
Once we have the channel, we detect that
Video playlist we can make you a
click to that click we react with
uncharted skin that populates data from
the analytics of that video
it's that simple we have this
development that we are seeing here that
we analyze of course in a very
simple through those of toulouse
there this seems like always
it seemed very useful lic
again very useful for some
applications to be here of course
that we're going to keep seeing some
more parts the analysis of the
code of the groups and the one who lost the
challenge of valleys comes a new challenge
it was quoted there is another challenge there is another challenge but
before I want to see to see where it is
to the camera our camera spy where
is
one-on-one
code code so I do not know where to
will also be there we are like this in the
group 9
well you can also vote for
supposed
where are we connected to
do promotion as yes exactly but
their successes
if I present the challenge to you if we are going to do
recharge our browser
if you think we are going to play role and that
it seems to play role and we go to quality and
software roll it look quickly I
I have here this device is a cable
that I'm going to take out only for you
you can see on the screen though I'll see
what is he doing if the person who
has the browser
still play roll it and that has to do
with all the groups here who lose
roll it with me and let's review the
code we also check the
two
so let's play of course here
in the browser
well this is a difficult opponent
I say I'm a tremendous opponent, good
yes, notice that quickly we're going to
watch
quickly we're going to go so we're going to
go look in the browser
to roddick
We're looking to go by phone
here it is very important that we see it and
Who are you going to play with? Let's play but
that's going to come in second
let's play role and from here with
Some of the participants could be
vote on the social network who wants that
play against the group that broker then
high vote which group you want to play
each role and with me we will throw yes for
course of the rolling and the one that adds more
share points and two opponents per
supposedly good wins and is not reviewed the
good code loses its successes you know
how are the rules here and we slide and
we work the look so we have left
two very important things we have left
go through the groups we are left
supposed to evaluate the code of it the
team that has already lost in the challenge of
couple that I do not dance well well so
those two groups we are going to analyze on 8
and the 10th remembering and we're going to play roll
it live with you and we continue
enjoying the code we continue
enjoying this adrenaline we continue
enjoying the ecosystem of Bogotá
what
engines to prepare you because it's coming
the challenge and we continue with much more
money in 2013 management votes
good morning my name is the laughs I am
the uncle recycles your mind like the
team number 8 and for us one of
the strongest competencies that exists
as programmers
the cloud team but they are not so good
competition as the number one team
who has presented a solution
integrator
and easy access to the community that
gives a solution to a big problem
globally that is the problem of
hello cooperativism my name is michael
martínez I am from group 7 our
project is called best place
We believe that we have a new project in
that moment here within the
convocation despite the fact that the others
projects are also very good but
we have really wanted to do this and
I really think we're going to
channel hello my name is cristian al
I am part of the yale team
business and well the competition
here in the develop boiler I think that
everyone has shown great talent
everyone has a lot of capacity to
develop a good project and ideas
that you have seen are very good inside me
I think they are all competences
really hello my name is Jesus
contreras I belong to group 5 and so
we really think that the teams are
good there are very good teams but
We have the best product and we know that
is going to be the best application my name
is what they did and claw in our group
it's called one it
and then many groups with very good
proposals that respected has very
good proposals but especially I think
that the davis plus proposal
I think it's very good
okay, we still enjoy this
live it but you 2013 here in Bogota
among them college campus
sergio grove bank especially
thank all of course
our technological friends not if it is
mine that juries now get inside
little because the assessment is coming
end of the applications the winner to
silicon valley of colombia fac very
true very true the winner goes with
us up silicon valley where
we have a very special event that
they will spend incredible
well it's time to play we're going to
analyze
I think we analyze the code
first we play first eggs
first and then let's ask
second to know if someone has any
preference yes and if not I went down to look
directly went down search because here
it's very important let's play roll it
so it was accompanied by some
preference
recite me
recíclame a nick against jesse work there
two against and sword and against recycle
yes work is around here who plays
on this side
and do not worry
for playing
that's why I feel like I saw it there
as saying I'm scared because neither
is a heavyweight in role is first time
I play it but I'm going to give it a fight
do not worry do not worry we are
they are good so
alone and I also the first time
I play it so I can not think of a lie
do not worry voices and middle tone like that
to accompany me here come here
let's play role and conget war come
around here we are going to quickly
convert comment to the public here
we left and we are already seeing buses and
we are all seeing and we are seeing your
phone if you want to raise a little
yes yield and yes of course good here
we have the phone we will see that here
we have it of course we are going to look
as you can see if you to this
and selecting things and here software
roll it roll it is very simple avant
rolling has to do with invoking things
if we are going to invoke coins and who takes out
more points yes of course whoever is
who more point in that context
winning the challenge is very simple
let's show we are in the browser
now let's go to the 2.0 bar phone
roll it yes here we have it let's go to
see what I put wrong
graus there we go very large fabrics ni
I have very big fingers and I have two very
great and I'm writing badly I'm
writing badly I have a problem myself
I need to spend
we have a little problem because it's not
I can enter the roll it
because I'm writing badly
nobody had put me what happened what happened
that is a lot of challenge here a lot
g.co challenge yes let's talk the
shortener and roll
here we already have this code here is not
asking you can you see we are going to
put that way what I'm doing
my phone we have to put the code
so that we are playing with world
broker if through html not
and we already have the activation notice that
you are looking to the right what
I'm doing here on the phone in
the phone we see perfect ok and to the
side will see what is happening
in the browser so let's choose
notice that I move the phone if
You can choose the number of plays of
players if your phone looks if
you want we can take out the window of your
phone and we see roll it roll and which
he wants to see this we take out this s we take
we get this ok and we play with 2 a
who since 2 we are going to play first
I'm going to play, let's say first
quickly to teach the Lord I
Let's go forward
here comes to money
and good but very bad very bad
very bad very bad with a little more than
strength was younger very young but that
long ago we go again with a little
more than strength there is almost hit 50 a
little bit more to see 10 points for me in
points how many shots after 30 for 30 min
we're still pulling
I'm with the next one is adding
and we're close to them I have 32 left
shots again let's see to see come
three shots to see if I can calibrate it
what happened I already lost but I come very badly
lack force lack force will pass pass
more arepa
or very strong or very very slowly let's say
I already have 40 points only it seems that
is saved and sword that I think there
no no I did not break it good player 2 and in the
sir come here an unfortunate in
the lucky game in the dance
do not bother him a bit do not worry
well this is good it bothers a little and
he left that I need it follows
bothering a little and it's work and it's work
there he went again he lost he won
has more pull
nothing is nervous the days are approaching
is disconnecting the cable
is commenting on xerez is approaching with
I'm going to do this, I do not understand and
he fell that he has no more shots
in Argentina for now no no no no longer
it was that the
well no, nobody realized that I
win 40 30 thank you very much
stop and let's go more than barbarian we're going
to review the code also to you that
you are there having fun with us
you want someone else to play against me
want to challenge you can vote for
supposed to vote it so good
as you will see we continue to see
code we keep having fun in this
duel but you 2013 and the moment arrives
to see the technical part I'm going to call it
out there we have mayer come come by
here our mentor there is one of the
star mentors approaching next to
we
look here comes here comes does more ago
a few minutes ago we were in another live
doing a dance game here the
team 10 and team 8 lost the game
dance dance not a vallenato if you
he missed it because it was awesome
really this so now we're going to
enter the repository if it seems to
commenting on some things it is clear
more or less the projects as they come
of group 10
and of group number 8 so the
second microphone stays here and here
let's go comment a little bit if
after this tremendous victory
tremendous victory in really I'm very
happy without cheating without cheating never by
your work this is totally like this we play
let's say you saw that you're there what
You saw me win in the whole law
well let's see here we have the repository
we are going to enter bogota
the presentation of the project we have the
project is going to move and it's work yes 19
hours ago he made the last comic so
well they are there they must be doing the
last arrangements not what happened not here
there was an extension yes
let's quickly see how you saw them
beyond this team let's say I'm going to
go touching some squares of color and
some code segments
the guys yesterday were working
strong as trying to integrate with
jim ok
'not with java on google app engine and
yesterday they had as difficulty is a little
how they did not have a little battle with
but today I saw them much more
solid today I saw that they have as
integrated all the cde cadafe in
Chile is working very well and
they could already integrate as the
tata store to store the data for
have as all the information as
saved on the infrastructure
scalable then they are on the right track
in that sense and they are starting how
put together the things that you see is to say
they are trying to show us already
results try to show the
juries what they are capable of
do what good good I'm looking at
out let's see let's see I was
seeing the extension you need and we
will show and there we are good was
reviewing the extension below the
projects we said already work
here I saw the extension very quickly and
here I am seeing the application in aena
pen without seemingly we will see by
example let's see the company jsp you
it seems and we're going to look at the
code as well as you're seeing there we're going to
criticize the code but always fine
constructive me too from the network
social you can comment on the code
knicks and notice there is usually a
valuation of the people of vélez la
smudge code quality because there
we are seeing have the airs
there are some tips here that I am seeing well
Well, it is usually very good practice
separate the entire presentation layer from
the layer
logic that has to do with the bases
of data then
remember that I asked you in some
moment if you were using it as a
template templates engine is
normally it is necessary to do is
say your code improves and it's much more
easy to maintain to the extent that
you have those layers apart after having
some files where you have the html and
you can use a template engine
like jim and for example that makes you very
easy life to do all the
presentation logic repeat blocks
include other templates for
that you do not have to put the code of
java in this case within the center
let's say that is one of the parties as
important within the strategy that
you chose let's say that you
they decided to create the entire application
including as the html code and
and let's say as the logical layer now to me
personally I like more the
applications where one has the
backend as totally clean and you
about that creates services services rest
what can you call, say, from a
application on android from a
application in javascript using as
many bookstores or even from a
desktop application from what you
you want the command line if you
it looks like a simile clouds wins true
exactly as something that gives you service
it stands independently is totally like
you backend that is going to get you going
deliver data to whatever you call it
then that is a very good practice
you left as if by a
strategy a little different under the
strategy that you used
let's say that what I would recommend
technically would be to try
separate the html code and use a
language as templates to organize
a little better the thing that I value many
thanks most impressive the return
of course how we accomplish successes
we fulfill why
they lost the challenge had to go see
the source code and the but it was
constructive now let's see I invite you
older let's see another one because the couple
was satisfied by the number 10
you open them yes and by the number group
8 who is on his back the gentleman over there
they do not love us and look good
but that was fine there if I had
something to say sir to see come
come with me because I had something to say
Mr. and we go back to review the code
come with me and we will see omar if not
I remember if omar omar martín and something
to say how you lived about the
dance let's say why
very well very well clear
all very well and we saw something in the networks
social who were calling the bus
success for him to dance already
and dance following all the
members to each of the duty or per
bus I want to get to our driver
dancing is very difficult with wheels but
buses we are going to experience that good
for let's review your code now
as it is already there so it receives
recyclable truth and recycle come
with me join me we continue we return to
throne seems this one works from that
we have here let's quickly see the
code we do have available in the
projects of the taca taca taca group
I have to check it you have to show a
little of the code or because this one I have not
still in detail today I would like
or find it to the code
ay albéniz and sword that disposed want it
ants but what happened to the group
number 8 was quoted what happened that has
happened is the code here the code and
we had to review it and there is the
code
I want silence here to see what you think
the social network because what people think
your comments there to see to see what
is happening because he got the
review lost the dance challenge
they wanted to download with the vuce cited
saying the lights equals and I would say
that now they have to dance again that
dance again and dance again
then let's do it again is going to
return to dance group number 8
follow me around here but we have to
find a partner to love so
I come sea will have to dance again
because unfortunately he did not comply with the
challenge can choose some of its levels
but also so do not worry if
you want you can choose any of your
levels for that dance but for July
come July around here July we are going to
choose your partner come with me if you already
we play roll it's seconds ago again
again now three will come back again
July whom we choose to dance to
comes the second dance of the day itself
follows the vallenato here in Colombia
doing
so who who has his partner
you have to choose quickly quickly
July
what would you have the possibility
time to choose so we go that does not
You can say that it is not like anybody
like fish in the water of payment July who
who accompanies it can be any
person who is inside
the project manager of group 4 to see
let me accompany me
identified 2 group number 3 month and going
approaching group number 4 and I see gray like that
what should be to see the project manager of
luxury 420 as long as it does not come with me
as its name
come with me paris we are accompanying
we continue enjoying in this nursery
probos 2013 watch follow the challenges
the challenges continue, group number 8 does not
fulfilled we reviewed the code was not in
the challenge of dancing again
to dance again
the vallenato is coming July is
prepared I have prepared that the
music voices milestone 20 seconds leads
we go
that comes the clear palm that comes the
palm down I know if all my speed
that's fine
the cricket fell in love with the law of command
glory
if it goes well back
there is a big hug for July then
I tell you I tell the boy too
we really saw the steps of the
vallenato I'm learning how to
to dance vallenato too so very
interesting this good we're going to take
a few seconds we go down takes a few seconds
and we have a lot more to offer you
still in this previous one is prior to the
grand finale that comes in 430 voices
He cited so we took a few seconds
we continue heating engines and we return
with much more and good but you
Hello my name is Guillermo León
angel business group
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there's no in the group
we are all simply very good at what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast good a tithe
gomez I am from the group of 7 is very 40%
but we have the certainty that I'm finished
tomorrow and we all have all contributed
many important things in the group
but I rescue our companion that
he has a lot of knowledge and does not help
contributed too much much more many
Thank you
good afternoon no man is July
access only part of the group
recyclable
we carry an approximate 75 percent
of the project and therefore
we consider our genius
it has always been our project manager
who was he
who originated the idea good my name
is Ricardo Chiriboga from the group of
agronomy
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager because
they have tried to guide us
about the idea my friend didier is
commissioning the front end part and
the backend submit them at 40 per
we are missing is to put the services
encouraged in so that front person
in two
and well we still in this nursery but
2013 we saw how to develop the back in
groups are still working with you
can see you live a lot of energy
technological here in this beautiful
college campus near valera
so thank you very much and we had for
close because we had seeing code
they also did not comply with the slogan
group over eight and had to repeat
the reyno dance very good dance very good
so measured dance yes it says but it goes
there goes there goes perfect and the
moment comes the moment of the second
role challenge and now I played and I showed
everything here on the court I played soccer
also dance you did not see it but
if not now because we want to see in
guanabacoa
we want to see play for four we want
watch play for which role and but look
we continue because now I'm going to select
and I'll surprise you with this golden
only the participants play here
but mentors also play at
role and so we continue here I'm going to
come to the middle and I see one of
the mentors that is super there
pensive to play with paco the role and
went down to corpac al jalifa and diego mini
with me benítez for here sumate come
for hair
loud applause plays the role and young
it's better than dancing
play the role and we will take the role and
I say how are you I see you well there mentor and
I walk the equipment all in order
we have we have to clear
we're looking at I think things are
they are clarifying a little more the
competition every time I think it's more
closed and I think we are already arriving
at the end I think we are already looking at
the finalists that are going to take us
let's go all together so that all the
team and I of course for the silicon
valley was not final
you think I say the easy let's play
with him with the telefonito paco is going to be
the opponent in this case that game
that is an opponent so very calm
but to see what he thinks basic recipe
come and come with me come six months
and I will follow very slowly and we will
play roll it paco western roll it me
says that's a role expert
that was running I come here
here we have our role and chat
configured we will not let you play
first who plays first to see what
the public first says very well who
play
diego first caused by code to play
first if it comes at one o'clock and two o'clock
three plays said first
for ccoo first
well let's put then king of yes
and if we already have the role there and prepared
for ccoo I'll make you delivery there
we are seeing was quoted now I left you
better accommodated there we are better here
let's see what Paco is playing
we have confirmed if now we are going to
choose and it comes comes with jupp and
play paco here to right
no other if you have to throw it just like that
as a movement there is shot for 10
let's go again there comes the second shot
and he spent a little bit but almost in
change has a good swing has a
important style is the golfer
and I say by a hundred was the most correct I
This is very good for goya 40-40
well for ccoo we go then with the role
and a little bit of air goes by without
We're going with a little more diego than
continue singing that you have here
60 is higher so far keeps that
comes and please how can this be a
expert harold and since long time ago
tremendous and the last shot is coming to
it came that he has it difficult if he hollowed
that essence
let's see let's see
Player 2 prepared from the optimal law
I would like you to ask about the team
two
dear ones
how come help is because of
telecom force adele frozen well
there's threw it today 40 I say diego is coming
also very good mexico when not
we have with the revision that code all
they lost by the way
nothing is just an error that comes
all right
under which you are disconnecting the
application but it does not come
center to center in the tower
putting the credit card
to 90 it is defined to what barbarian that barbarian
ay ay ay ay ay ok just tied
you do not leave sad anymore and I
it looks like the tax we're already going through the hotel
also all together
but it's loud applause for those who
they add to the development
payment also come come that does not happen
nothing next time we cheat
with closed eyes also look
how much thank you very much diego applause
all right
good nick but we had said that
it happened with the one who lost the one who wins
danced with Mercedes was the payment rule te
like that you like seven and diego come and
I say with this who mercedes counting
who Mercedes Benz and Diego see and I say
here that their challenge does not end
rules change every five minutes
who dance with mercedes is a prize
diego clara diego award is a prize
so I've connected your successes
yes it seems we make the challenge
ten seconds of vallenato and is
just a one-step demonstration
here and a step there give him if
we use friend who has very good wave
that continues against us to see paco
paco decime marca me quiero mercedes
because I do not know where you are
I think it is for everyone to know
ask mercedes to come to mercedes
forward prepared the next comes the
dance do not miss it we continue
enjoying code we saw a little bit of
google + haining we saw of course something
from youtube and arrives at Mercedes 10
vallenato seconds carefully diego
well but it's a prize has a mercedes
here to dance is a prize and it is
rejecting live so come come
10 seconds
there is very good
to see, I do not know, that's fine
have you are also
the presence of snow
and they say that in colombia they are very very
very happy and we are seeing
and in Spanish of course thank you very much
loud applause then loud applause
thanks diego wind through
Colombia Spain Colombia Spain as
We are living in this nursery but you
2013 of course so good we
we take a few seconds and we close
I live because the great
final voices and everything comes the great
end so you're there connected
following minute by minute
is happy little light we take some
seconds let's conclude with this vigo
we took a second to stay there
connected and prepare for the great
end so now we have in seconds in
seconds with more level to see more 2013
edition
william lion of the group and the business
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we're learning python like crazy
and I think there's no group
we are all simply very good what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast just like
gomez I am from group 7 we are at 40
cent but we have the certainty that both
they finish tomorrow and we all have all
contributed many important things in the
group but I rescued our
partner who has a lot of knowledge and
I have not contributed much much more
thank you
good afternoon no name is july
I'm an arm member of the group
recycle then we take an approximate
75 percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
It has always been our own manager
who was he
that who originated the idea good my
name is ricardo chiriboga
the agronomy group
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager because
they have tried to guide us
about the idea my friend
Didier is taking care of the part
of the front end and the back in the increase of
the average by 40% we need is
put the services at point to
the person of fernando his
we continue in this nursery 2003 edition
vote how are we how many of the
chickens we had a lot of fun themselves
codes
we also interact socially with
you're there connected
we thank gurí martínez very much
Arming picón iván spa wheel is
really great amount
merche too many messages pacos
a lot of messages like that is all the
community is following closely the
developer voice in in Bogota we are all
waiting for the final and the teams continue
Exact working and pako we have today
after the final the announcement is here
there is the fest bogota there is also but
a lot of football players are like that
is we have a thousand registered to everyone
they choose before we're going to get there with the
bus teams is there let's go back to
present the winner and then party
party also exact so
awesome how are we living this
approved level is we saw scenarios of
code we reviewed the groups we did
We made challenges mentors participated
how much adrenaline does this bus have
flavor of Colombian of course is the
Colombian color the flavor of Colombia
the ultimate expression so the
we invite the last live of this
Colombian scenario 4 30pm at 4:30 p.m.
time to vote user minus 5 you go to
can see the grand finale who of all
the groups wins
the jury evaluating of course and all
that adrenaline of knowing who the
representative in the silicon valley as well
that we invite you not to miss it for
course we can follow all the
information minute by minute in the
developer community in
google developers also the
we invite you to join and join us
in this technological flow that proposes
the voice developer so we prepare
for ccoo we prepare ourselves for the great
all the judges are already through
here giving back to the mentors it
are evaluating and we will have at 16
30 at 4 30pm in the use of number 3
the grand finale goes co so it's
perfectible nick do not miss it
unmissable as unmissable
to you who are there connected that you are going to
live your adrenaline
technological you're going to meet the winner
of the book by busse Bogotá
we say that the 430 we turn to
find with the great the great the great
final the grand finale that we are going to live
with all this Colombian color then
430 is the proposal that we make to you
to come back with a lot but a lot more
with a lot of adrenaline from this bus edition
2013 vote see you at 4:30 with the
Grand finale
Hello my name is Guillermo León
angel business group
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we're learning python like crazy